pin spins up the the videos of the
panelists
so um so our panelists today include
scott harrinson who again needs no
introduction here he was a speaker and a
panelist before
let me just give the update that as of
his last appearance here he
won the acm prize for computing so
congrats uh scott
we have uh sergio braxo who is
chief scientist at google i believe uh
sergio was one of the one of the
you know major players in the in in this
whole
uh benchmarking for this for the quantum
supremacy experiment at
google so uh it's really great to have
you here
uh sergio um we have uh
uh steve flamia who until recently was
at the university of sydney and who is
now
at the aws center for quantum computing
uh
steve um is an expert in quantum
information
uh especially as applied to condensed
matter theory and to
air correction and in fact he's done a
lot of work on
on learning uh you know benchmarking
errors in
in uh near quantum systems so
uh welcome steve and uh and then we have
uh
joseph emerson who is uh who is on the
faculty
at uh um the institute for quantum
computing and at the university of
waterloo he's also the ceo and founder
of quantum
benchmarks so uh again welcome
uh joseph and so um
uh i i guess um uh
uh you know john john gave just uh
i mean there's a there's a lot to chew
on and from uh from john stock
so you know there's there's plenty to
address there but
i'd also like to broaden the topic out
to quantum benchmarking
um which is which is clearly something
that's going to play a
play a big role as we move ahead with
with quantum devices
um so um i'm sorry
uh i hope john's video is also being
pinned
uh
so um so uh
um you know when when when i was a
student here at berkeley i
there was there was a architecture
professor who um
who who said
that you know that
that the most important application of
computers
is designing better computers um
it was it was probably true at that time
in in computer
science and maybe it's going to be true
in in quantum computation at this
this particular point in time so so
anyway
i i guess um with respect to uh
quantum bench benchmarking of course we
want to learn
what what our current day quantum
computers are you know in terms of how
well they're doing
how to improve them how to how to
understand the error models in there
and so you know it would be great to
hear your viewers about
about that too so perhaps we can go
through um
you know uh one by one uh if you can
speak for a couple of minutes
uh about any of these topics so we start
with scots and stuff
all right well yeah so i'm i'm grateful
to john for uh
an exceptionally clear uh presentation
of
one of my favorite results of the last
uh
you know a couple of years about uh uh
you know learning of quantum states
i mean i have been interested uh for a
very long time
in this business of how can you predict
many properties of a quantum state from
few measurements of that state
i mean even before uh shadow tomography
uh in 2006 you know i had this paper
about pac learning of quantum states
right of uh or you know let's say i only
need to uh
predict a quantum state with respect
to most measurements that are drawn from
some distribution over measurements and
then
you know i showed that you could do that
with a number of samples that grows only
linearly with the number of qubits and
that was
uh uh that that that result was actually
what
a part of what what led me to formulate
the question
of you know is shadow demography
possible
or not and you know my suspicion was
probably it's not possible but you know
this was one of those cases where
you fail to prove something is
impossible and then you know ultimately
you
discover the the barrier to the
impossibility proof was what was
was that it is possible so
um but you know i've i've also so i
guess
you know for 15 years you know i've
talked to
uh experimentalists about you know i've
tried to interest them
in these ideas of uh um
of uh of sort of uh uh um quick and
dirty quantum state tomography that
could be you know exponentially more uh
efficient than the full kind and you
know there there's been a lot of
curiosity about it but
you know there's also been sort of i
think some major barriers that have sort
of prevented them from really you know
using it for anything practical
right one difficulty has been just the
complication of the measurements that
you had to perform
you know in the sorts of protocols that
uh that i explored
john um mentioned that in his talk but
you know a second
issue is you know the occasional
difficulty right just because
you can do something with a number of
measurements that's linear in the number
of qubits
doesn't mean that you can actually do
the computation
that efficiently right and that might
still require
exponential and n computation okay but i
think
maybe the biggest issue has been the
lack of a sort of killer application
you know and and what's happened again
and again is that like once the
experimentalists specify what thing
they are interested in then often you
know there is a more direct way
you know if you just wanted to learn
that property of your state
or if you just wanted to learn all of
the k point correlation functions where
k is small
then there would be some much more
direct way to do that that wouldn't
require
you know the strength of these abstract
learning theories
right so you know listening to john's
talk um
you know i had uh you know i i
occasionally had that question in the
back of my head like you know
john you you talked about like learning
you know the ground state energy
right you're learning the energy of a
state like
if you just wanted to know the energy
then why not just sort of
directly estimate that right but uh
on the other hand what i like what i
really like about this classical shadows
idea
is that there is sort of one thing that
you can tell experimentalists to go out
and measure
you know namely you know the results of
like applying a bunch of random
unitaries from some
ensemble like random clifford circuits
for example and then just measuring
in the computational basis over and over
again and from that you can collect a
whole bunch of classical data
where you know you don't even have to
know in advance what that might be used
for
right you know you then have some
classical uh
archive archival record of this quantum
state
that could be then called upon later for
for something that you might not have
even thought of at the time
and so i think that that's precisely
what could have a lot of appeal
to um experimentalists and yeah i hope
that more
you know uh applications will be
discovered that really you know sort of
uh
draw on this and use it and and need it
great thanks scott
um sergio hi
sir um yes uh i guess uh
you were posting the question what are
uh
current experimental quantum computers
good for and why it's important to keep
benchmarking them
um and i think yeah you your answer is a
pretty good one you know to build better
quantum computers
especially when we're thinking on the
long term plan of
falter and quantum computation is you
know
very difficult to have really advanced
precise enough
models that tells us how we need to keep
improving the system making sure that we
have
all correlations under control lately
you know we're very worried about
cosmic rays for instance there is a lot
of work that we are going to have to be
to do there to mitigate the effect of
cosmic rays by
removing energy from chips so clearly in
the context of error correction
it's very important to keep doing
experiments and improve our models
to guide the design of new generations
of
super conducting qubits in particular
and i will guess the same applies
to other systems so it's important to do
very detailed benchmarking uh to improve
models
and have a you know learning cycle to
keep improving designs
but also i think for nes algorithms uh
is as well very important to to do
experimentation as we keep improving
our algorithmic techniques i think
one particular point where
experimentation is very important is
general air mitigation techniques there
are many interesting
air mitigation techniques out there and
it's hard to see a priori which one is
going to work
better or worse for a particular
experiment and
on that note for instance one of the
papers we have done recently at google
one of the experiments was the
information scrambling experiments
looking at autocorrelations
and uh i think we found something
interesting there which is that once you
apply
all the error mitigation techniques we
could think of and we compare against
the latest algorithms for
simulating these kind of circuits these
were random circuits it was information
describing random circuits
so when we compare with the
classical cost of simulating the same
circles with the latest techniques which
is basically
tensor networks with hyper-optimized
contractions
the conclusion is that we need to lower
our
error rates by a factor of a half to be
able to measure auto
observables in a regime that we cannot
simulate classically anymore
um so the one hand that's encouraging is
just you know a factor of one half is
not a factor of a hundred on the other
hand you know lowering error rates by a
factor of a half
is hard and i guess the point i'm trying
to make is that uh
this particular estimate that we need to
lower rates by a factor of a half that
will be very hard to do
without actually running experiments
because that includes a lot of error
mitigation
techniques and it wasn't easy to see a
priority which our mitigation techniques
were going to work better in this
particular case it turned out that
some sort of error extrapolation where
we kind of
um implement clifford circuits which
were in the support of the random
circuits that we care about and you know
because they are clifford we can measure
everything exactly then we can get the
constants to do proper error
extrapolation um you know that that
particular technique worked well but
it's kind of an involved technique
that you know it wasn't a pretty area
guess like i just
try clear four circles on the support of
the random circuit that you care about
so yeah i think um experimentation and
benchmarking with
actual devices is is quite important
great thanks sergio um
stephen
right so um i guess scott and sergio
touched on this point but
um since you have you asked us to
discuss
uh benchmarking more generally is what i
think you said
uh i think it's important that we
distinguish two different notions of
benchmarking that are used
uh in the literature so uh the first is
what
might be called error benchmarking and
the other is what might be called
application benchmarking
so uh if you talk about error
benchmarking you're talking about
estimating error rates which sergio
alluded to
and if you're talking about application
benchmarking you're talking about how
well
is a specific quantum device going to
perform at a specific task
um and there uh these are two separate
things for which the community
unfortunately uses the same word
uh so there's some confusion there um
and i think that actually classical
shadows
is going to be useful for both of these
regimes
i think that we can learn a lot from the
type of randomized experiments
that john talked about using uh
estimation from classical shadow
estimation in fact for
one of the reasons that scott talked
about which is namely that you can sort
of collect this data in advance
with these randomized experiments and
you don't even have to know what you're
going to process it for so you can after
the fact
decide to do things like model testing
and model selection on the
error benchmarking side to try to
determine error rates
um and you can also try to process that
data to try to see
you know you're interested specifically
in estimating an energy of some
local hamiltonian for example is a an
application of
these classical shadow techniques but
you can also use that
data those same data can be used for
estimating the usefulness for some other
tasks potentially it depends on the
structure of the circuits
uh but i believe the classical shadows
will find applications like this in the
future
so i'm excited i think um keeping these
so what sergio also another point that
sergio made is uh
that error mitigation is important i
mean error mitigation is like a jargon
term that our field
uh came up with because of uh high
impact paper that was published but it's
really just de-biasing
um our community isn't the first to
invent this
notion that if you have biased
estimators you have to remove the bias
on those estimators
um we use error mitigation in this
specific context
so i think all of these things are going
to be extremely important i think
classical shadows are going to play
an important role in all three of these
things moving forward
sorry thanks steve um uh just
well thanks uh yeah thank you for the
presentation john and
am i muted yeah i'm not good um and uh
thanks for the invitation to uh
participate in the panel um yeah with
actually i'd like to kind of rip off of
what steve was talking about
uh first of all the terminology i you
know i totally agree
that benchmarking is kind of an
overloaded term
um i tend to use it to mean both of
those things unfortunately but you know
when i'm on my best behavior
it's benchmarking the notion of
benchmarking that we care about
is really error diagnosis error
characterization
um and you know i think i think we have
kind of our you know human weakness to
want to
turn this into a competition and talk
about benchmarks that can compare
platforms
but i think ultimately it's it's really
too early for that we should be focused
theoretically and academically and in
industry on uh you know air diagnostics
and in particular air
diagnostics that help us get to the
killer app which is quantum error
correction and so
i try to use the word error diagnostic
to mean you know we need a lot of
information
you you know it's it's a kind of it's
easy for people to oversimplify the idea
that
you know getting to the fault tolerant
regime was about proving you have this
one benchmarking number that's below
threshold and really
you know noise is complex and to
understand the overheads
um involved and the most effective error
correction strategy and decoding
strategy we need
detailed information detailed
diagnostics about the errors and i think
that
in terms of work that's going to move
the field forward i feel like that's
the biggest priority is to pull that
information out and fold it into a
process where we can start
you know making positive you know strong
inferences
um you know like scott was saying about
you can just measure the certain number
of
measurements and predict a lot of
properties of the state you might find
out later
and you know we need we need that
process in place for uh for air channels
to understand um you know what it what
are the details of the error channel
which will inform our decisions about
how to
ultimately not just you know mitigate
the errors but but correct them
through an error correction layer so
i'll just keep my comments brief and say
i
you know i think that's the biggest
challenge in front of the field right
now
great thanks thanks joseph uh john would
you like to
respond well i guess i have
i'd like to ask a question to the panel
um that
this was kind of addressed
by joseph and steve but our big
challenge
uh in the nescara is noise mitigation
uh you know joseph said well one of the
reasons we want error diagnostics is to
advance us on the path to fault
tolerance
steve spoke of the importance of
um reversing bias and estimators
but i get i i would be interested in
your perspective
on how much headroom there is for noid
noise mitigation in the in the nisk era
do you think
um that uh it's possible to come up
i mean a lot of people have offered
various ideas
for uh you know trying to
get useful results out of noisy
platforms
but you think there's opportunities to
make big advances there which might make
nisk technology uh much more useful
oh joe do you want to go i saw you on
youtube
i've been unmuted so it's an indicator
but
i'm happy to just maybe i'll start a bit
and you can follow up steve um
i think there is a big opportunity but
we need to know more about the nature of
the errors the extent to which their
you know i think calibration errors we
can make a lot of progress
i mean ultimately there's limitations in
finite control one of the things i like
to say which
you know it took me a long time to kind
of realize this is the right way to
think about things
is we talk about decoherence as the as
the
achilles heel for quantum computing
but you know the more work i've done
with experimentalists the more i realize
that in a sense
depending on how you define that term
that's actually not the problem the
problem is calibration and control
errors
we have we're using you know finite
precision analog signals to get
you know some kind of continuous
rotations in hilbert space and
there's always going to be a finite
precision limitation and these
these coherent errors can have very
negative effects
first of all they're ubiquitous and they
can be very problematic they don't fit
our simplest kind of theoretical models
and so um you know i think there is a
lot of of
promise to mitigate those errors
through um you know control
strategies informed control strategies
in particular
uh whereas i think you know problems of
decoherence where it's straight up
coupling to an environment that's
outside of our control uh you know i
think that's really up to the fab
process which is outside of me
my wheelhouse and there i can't really
speak to what can be done at that level
steve do you want to take it from there
yeah so john you asked uh you know how
much room
is there for progress on uh noise
mitigation and
near-term quantum devices i think there
is room for a lot of progress
i think a lot of the techniques are
going to have
bad scaling possibly exponential scaling
although there have been some papers
that
um have a promising scaling
um and i don't think that
that's necessarily a bad thing uh you
know if you throw
some mild exponential scaling of
classical resources it's something to
unlock
a better uh scaling from your
quantum resources uh that's great and if
you manage to actually do something
useful
wow you know that would be fantastic
right that's what we're all hoping
we can achieve what we'll really get out
of all this
is uh going back to what umesh said
we'll learn how to build better quantum
computers
from doing this so um i think that uh
there's gonna be huge payoffs
from the investment that we make in
these ideas
do i think do i believe that we're
actually going to be able to use noise
mitigation techniques to do a useful
quantum computation that can't be done
let's say easily classically or maybe
not done at all
uh on on a huge cloud uh computer
um i wouldn't put great odds on it
um i'm not super optimistic but
you know uh hopefully i'm wrong um
but i do think that it's going to unlock
a lot of power uh
in future devices where we do have error
correction and fault tolerance
if i can jump in again i might be
speaking to the wrong topic so
i've been using the term error
mitigation to really mean kind of any
method that's
gonna going to suppress the native
hardware errors whether it's
you know anything from you know you know
decoupling pi
pulses to compiling strategies
to the methods that were proposed around
extrapolation
extrapolating performance based on some
assumptions i was mainly talking about
extrapolation rather than things like
dynamical decoupling sequences but um
okay so anything is fair game to reduce
noise but
once you have the data trying to
remove that noise post-facto
uh that i think is challenging
generally often has bad scaling and
um it's not clear to me that we're going
to get a quantum advantage
um uh by using those
techniques i think without those
techniques uh things are even worse off
so we should be using those techniques
um and like i said the investments that
we put into developing those techniques
are only going to help us build actual
quantum computers which is going to you
know
by which i mean fall tolerant
error-corrected quantum computers so
i'm all in for these ideas i think
they're great i'm not super optimistic
that we're actually going to get
a quantum advantage from those
techniques if they don't come in tandem
with other improvements elsewhere so
yeah so in that in the narrower context
of that type of error mitigation
you know i'd have to say i'm a bit
skeptical about how effective it will be
in a context where we can't verify that
the
extrapolated solution is correct by
independent means
uh i'd be you know i'd be worried about
that
um shall i try to address the question
a little bit um yeah
the main problem from aramaication is
that
it's it's not removing errors and
fidelity is of course decreasing
financially
with the number of gates right uh so you
know if you want to do
more than 50 cubits and that 50 well
then you're likely to have pretty low
fidelity maybe you can get 100 cubits
that's 100
but but fidelity keeps decreasing
exponentially the current techniques
in our mitigation which is not a
reaction they're going to scale
as one over fidelity square or another
fidelity so i think that the current
techniques that i know but actually
whenever fidelity is square
and they you know of course you want to
remove four controllers and calibration
errors first if you
you can but then you're still going to
be left with you know an
things like that which is coupled into
an environment you cannot remove that
current remediation techniques are
limited uh they have a cost which was
like one
over fidelity square so that you know
limits the application of
of paramitigate which is not our
correction i think what would be
great is to find our mitigation network
detection
with a cost that would go like one over
f and
that's probably the best we can achieve
in bottom calling our mitigation
that means sort of actually removing
errors so i think the best you can do
is go for a technique which allows you
to flag errors and then you just
process remove all the data with errors
out of your sampling
and assuming that you can do that
without introducing any overhead in the
shortcuts
then the best you can hope for is that
um
you know the cost of the optimal
navigation will be one over
f but you know as fidelity keeps
decreasing especially this is still
limited
and the other thing i would like to say
is that i am i think more optimistic
about finding uh european classical
applications or
quantum advanced applications in the
niskara in some specific
areas you know um for instance i
mentioned autocore information rambling
which is you know looking at correlators
of operators or
really random circuits and and we're
only a factor of a half away from that i
think probably for
you know spin diffusion or our boss have
our models
um you know we're eventually gonna get
um
beyond classical simulations on this got
more
you know pessimistic about fermionic
simulations at least with super nothing
cubes because of all the overhead
but in some areas which you know
versions of random circuits
and and maybe spin diffusion i think
we'll we're likely to
you know get somewhere in this
great um initially shall we see if the
audience has any
questions
um
there are some questions in the chat and
the q a
yes so i'm not sure if you can see that
so there is a there is a question about
peter
m in the chat
uh so well uh can anyone comment on the
claim by psy quantum
where they
i'm sure we all hope it's true
i think john should comment on that
it's good to have ambitious goals
okay um
so um anyone else um
maybe i can ask a question if you'd like
yeah
please john sorry for my negative
tone of question earlier um i really do
like classical shadows a great deal and
i'm
happy the panel is discussing noise
because i i have this fundamental belief
that
no algorithm is real unless it survives
finite amount of noise um and so i'd
like to push
and see how far it can go but one
direction that occurred to me during
your discussion might be to ask
do you the panel believe that we could
turn this around and utilize shadow
tomography or
classical shadows to study noise
and use it as a technique to understand
noise processes because as you said john
if it's like independent noise it may
not affect it
if it's biased noise it will affect it
if it's highly correlated noise it
will probably affect it more many
quantum noise sources are highly
correlated
i don't i wonder what do you think
well i deferred steve as the well and
joseph
as the experts on noise characterization
i think the answer is yes mike uh i i
think that this can be done
um i i have a few thoughts about it even
but they're probably not ready for
they're they're not uh they're still
quarter baked or maybe half baked so
uh maybe in the future
we can talk about that more but i think
it should be possible
while we are waiting for anybody else to
ask questions let me
let me uh ask a question john
uh so do you have a
you know do you have a sort of a
heuristic you know way of thinking about
this in terms of
you know what are those those tasks or
you know where classical shadows you
know
that where the efficiency in terms of
computation or or samples
you know what's what's that set of tasks
where this is going to be
efficient
oh this is for me right yeah um
well i don't know i gave
some examples
and they're probably the best examples i
could offer
um but i think we can
benefit i'm kind of thinking broadly
about it
um that um
you know because it's i think it's a key
question for the near term so we're
going to have
quantum platforms and we'll be able to
prepare certain kinds of states and then
we want to use them to do something
useful
and um we don't want to
rely on uh you know relatively high
depth
quantum circuits and so if we have the
tool to take that quantum state
and translate it into a succinct
classical description that's useful for
things then
you know in searching for applications i
would suggest
thinking about you know what are the
applications which can run if we have
classical shadows as inputs
and that was what i tried to illustrate
with the machine learning examples
yeah that you know we have all this
wonderful machinery
for classical machine learning and
if we have quantum platform which can
prepare states which are not so easy to
prepare classically
of course maybe that's a big if for the
near term um
you know then we have the opportunity to
you know use the power of that quantum
data to extend the reach of
machine learning tools so i think
there's a lot of
territory to explore there
see i have a follow-up question if i may
uh
scott and john um yeah so i mean i still
don't feel like i have a good intuition
about
how how this is even possible that such
you know
small number of measurements can be so
predictive so broadly
um could you maybe help me build up
intuition by maybe
giving me an example of something where
it wouldn't work
so i can kind of understand the
complexity that's lost i mean are there
use cases where this would be
insufficient like one thing that came to
mind is
when it came to estimating the hilbert
schmidt and her product which would be
relevant for fidelity estimation then
you needed the full
clifford rather than the tensor product
cliffords right so that's a
that's a quantum resource but it's still
the same small number of measurements so
it's more than small number of
measurements that surprises me i don't
know it's just it's an open-ended
question if any of you have any thoughts
on that
well i mean in the case of john's
protocol if the shadow norm is large
then it's going to require a lot of
samples
right i mean that's the thing that
controls uh
its efficiency right my protocol
is sort of harder to
implement but it's more general right
and that it would work for any
uh list of two outcome measurements like
any collection of quantum circuits
that you wanted and um you know
and and but but you know the you know to
just maybe maybe this will help your
your intuition a little in my
my procedure uh if you wanted to learn
the outcomes of
exponentially many different
measurements then you know although my
procedure only needs a polynomial number
of quantum
of copies of the state it will run for
an exponential amount of time
okay it will kind of you know make a
measurement and you know
uh it will make measurements basically
for for each
each measurement in your list that you
want right and
just do it in a very gentle way that
that only rarely disturbs the states by
much
okay but so it's a very inefficient
procedure you know the only thing that
we're optimizing is
you know the sample complexity the
number of copies of the state
right and so that's that's part of what
what makes it possible but of course
you know there's then an enormous space
to explore
in terms of well in what situations can
you also make this computationally
efficient
you know just just like with classical
machine learning you know first people
proved
you know results about sample complexity
saying like in principle here is you
know
like what you could aim for and then
people spent decades after that trying
to fill in the gap
with what actual procedures can we find
for learning that will also be
efficient computationally i guess a
simple example
would be learning a lot of uh highway
poly operators
um and i discussed that in the context
of the poly measurement protocol you
know that it was
you need an exponential number of
samples in the weight but
but even for the um for the clifford
protocol
i mean the hilbert schmidt norm is
exponential
if you know you just take the trace of
you're taking the trace of the identity
uh for n qubits when you square the poly
operator
so we uh we can't infer that we can
predict lots of highway poly operators
and maybe i can add something um
some intuition for why you might expect
a log m
scaling with these things so imagine
you're trying to do parameter estimation
uh and often people are interested in
the few parameter case or the one
parameter case and they are interested
in
achieving like an optimal constant given
by a fischer information or something
like this
but you just want to get maybe not the
optimal scaling but like good enough
precision uh but you have a large list
of parameters you have m
of them and you take data that is
somehow generic
in that it's informative a little bit
but not optimally about
all the parameters and that's what the
shadows do um
you can just recycle your data and apply
it to each of the parameters on the list
and you're like whoa whoa whoa but that
introduces huge dependencies and like
isn't that a major problem and
uh you would think that it would be but
if the failure probability of each one
is small
then you can take the union it's
decaying exponentially with all these
protocols you take the union bound over
all of them
and then you're done you just need a log
m factor to compensate
for uh like a statistician would call it
uh
multiple hypothesis testing correction
but uh i would call it the union bound
and um this this is what gives you the
log m scaling so
you know when you're trying to estimate
all these parameters you can do it in
bulk and you can recycle your original
data to do it
it's not going to always work there are
you know some caveats that come with
that
but like that's a that's a it's an
achievable goal in a lot of
circumstances
so you can you can aim for that and
you're not being unrealistic
with that expectation at least not a
priori
thank you steve i i should i should add
that steve
is actually the one who uh uh coined the
term
shadows in this context right when i had
some stupid name
for for the uh uh for the for this idea
and steve was like well why don't you
call it
shadow demography and like physicists
are really much better at naming
yeah i agree that's that's a great game
steve
is it from uh plato's cave the allegory
of plato's cave
yeah also like uh maybe it's worth since
i'm in a very public forum right now to
explain my
idea these aren't quite projections
because the things that you're measuring
don't commute
um so rather than calling them just
projections
of the quantum state uh there's some
kind of shadow
which i thought yeah yeah plato's cave
and of course i was thinking about
uh plato uh but i i should say in in
in my shadow tomography paper i did have
this observation that's you've mentioned
that
in the classical case so the case where
all of the shadows do commute
you know there the proof of the shadow
tomography theorem is just three
lines it's just the turn off bound and
the union bound
and that's where that log of m factor
comes from end of story right
the whole difficulty in the quantum case
is just that
measurements on quantum states can
destroy the state
and so now you have to be more careful
that was super helpful thanks guys great
i'd like to sharpen umesh's question if
there's a moment to do so
please okay so um you asked the panel if
there's something useful that could come
out of this
and it occurred to me listening to you
just now why not create the density
matrix and the states that you want from
a natural physical system that already
exists such as a bose-einstein
condensate that's evolving in a lattice
that might be doing some bozo hubbard
model or fermi hybrid model
why not look at a black hole
astrophysically and then do
a classical shadow tomography with
astrophysical measurements
do you believe in this
am i supposed to answer this um
so um so you're not you're not trying to
characterize
the quantum state of the black hole
you're just talking about a protocol
for using projections to
predict what exactly i'm not sure
the the astrophysical questions with i'm
leaving open
but clearly in the bose-einstein
condensate example
there's a natural physical system that
can be very complex and it's quantum and
it
may be accessible experimentally to
doing the shadows that you describe
okay well that's like a kind of
classical um
signal processing problem i guess that
you're talking about
which you probably know more about than
i do the way i
understood it he's replacing a quantum
computer with a
or a nisk device quantum computer which
has gates
with an analog quantum computer aka an
experiment
um but as long as you can access the
measurements of the output i think you
could
use it still
and so maybe classical shadow tomography
becomes a useful tool of quantum
experimentalists
and what i did have in mind is exactly
what you describe steve
yeah i mean i like to think of it also
as a quantum fingerprint but that name
is already taken
when i'm fingerprinting uh you know it's
a it's a succinct description
uh that lets you reconstruct a lot of
interesting information from a system
and it's easy to make these measurements
so people should do this
um great so maybe uh
uh shelby shall we wrap up here um so
this was uh thanks everybody for for a
terrific panel
and thanks again john for a wonderful
talk that was that was really
uh quite a treat um so
next week we'll have uh henry yung speak
about
a proof approach to a proof view of
mip star equal to re and um
and the and the week after we have
ronald dewolf
speaking about uh quantum algorithms for
optimization
um so if you'd like to continue to
the discussion uh we have a gather town
link
in the chat so please join us now
see you all next week thanks sir
you